[Music]  like walking with the Stars would be  like maybe I can do it the full lineup  for Dancing with the Stars athletes is  finally here  bring it on Friday the 10 athletes vying  for the Mirrorball trophy were revealed  on Good Morning America I've been saying  for 26 seasons put me on the cast will  include Kareem abdul-jabbar  I've always enjoyed dancing so you know  I'm gonna have some fun even if I don't  do well Johnny Damon marina gasps ooh  Chris Master Whitney is luckily a  fantastic coach we both speak sarcasm  fluently and it's it's some tough love  on the dance floor right now Josh Norman  it made me be at eppley he's gonna win  yes  Jennie Finch Tonya Harding I'm just  honored to be part of this and very  humbled as well Jamie Anderson  Arika algún wale and Adam rip on  attitudes and personality the mini  four-week edition of the dance  competition show will premiere April  30th  [Music]  [Applause]